so the story of prince yvonne and the
gray wolf
is one of the most famous russian fairy
tales around
and just recently actually just
yesterday
deacon nicholas kotar who many of you
have seen
on my channel he's the author of the
raven sun series
he's also been a pretty enthusiastic
participant in
the symbolic world blog actually his
articles
have gotten more views than my article
and so
so deacon nicholas has just started a
new podcast
called in a certain kingdom and his
podcast is going to be looking
at different russian fairy tales
giving a retelling of the fairy tales
and then giving some analysis as well
his retellings are very beautiful and
succinct
they keep the flavor of the russian
fairy tales with the certain
literary tropes that are used that are
almost like liturgical in the way that
they're used
so i'm pretty excited about it his first
episode was
a retelling of yvonne and the gray wolf
so myself i thought it would be a good
opportunity to celebrate this
new podcast to give my own
interpretation of that fairy tale which
of course
is one that i loved for a very long time
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so in order to give you my
interpretation i'm of course going to
give you a summary of the fairy tale
kind of give you the basic elements of
course my retelling
is going to be just bare bones and has
nothing to do with the retelling that
deacon nicholas gives in his podcast
the his retelling is beautiful there's
also a
some compositions that were written and
so there's music in the background
it's very it's very very well done very
professional i
once again suggest you check it out so
here
are the basic elements of prince yvonne
and the gray wolf
and so the king has a tree which
produces golden apples
and then the king realizes that there's
something which is stealing his golden
apples at night
there are different versions sometimes
it is seen that the guards have noticed
this uh firebird which escapes the
garden at night
and so the king asks his sons if they
would be willing
to try to catch the thief of these
golden apples
of course the king has three sons his
two older sons and the youngest who is
yvonne
so the two oldest agree and the king
doesn't want the youngest to get
involved
this will continue on through the fairy
tale so the
the first son goes in at night and
tries to wait for the thief but he falls
asleep
and he doesn't catch the firebird the
second son of course does the same falls
asleep
can't catch the firebird so prince
yvonne begs his father and his father
agrees so prince yvonne
goes in and he fights to stay awake
is successful at staying awake and then
sees the firebird come to steal the
golden apple
and so prince yvonne tries to catch it
but he's only able to grab
a tail feather of the bird as the bird
flies away
so the this is successful in chasing the
firebird away the firebird doesn't come
to get the apples anymore
but the king regrets the firebird when
he sees the beautiful
uh tail feather of the bird he regrets
it and wants
to uh to catch it and so he tells his
sons that whoever catches this firebird
will be his inheritor and will also get
half
the kingdom so of course the same thing
the father sends his two older sons
the younger son begs to be able to go
but the father says he's too young
and that he cannot so the two sons leave
to get the firebird and they come
to a fork in the road there are three
possibilities three roads ahead of them
there's a sign
at the crossroads which says that if you
take the first road you will
you will endure hunger and cold if you
take the second road
your horse will die and you will live
but if you take the third
the third road you will die and your
horse will live
and so the two sons not being able to
choose between the three paths
decide to just give up hang out there
and live an idle life
and so as the king is waiting for the
sons to come back they don't of course
and so finally yvonne begs his father
and the father lets him go
to go find the firebird so yvonne
reaches the sign in the road and decides
to take the second road
which is the one where his horse will
die but he will survive
so as he's going a grey wolf comes and
eats
his horse which leaves yvonne lost in
the forest
lost in the middle of nowhere walking
for days and days until he's exhausted
and can continue when finally the gray
wolf comes back to see him
apologizing for eating his horse and
then of course
offers him to help him there are some
versions where the wolf
asks uh prince yvonne to
uh if he if prince ivan would be willing
to give him his horse to eat which is a
very interesting take on it as well
and yvonne accepts and then the horse
gives his
help in return
and so the wolf says to get on his back
and that the wolf will bring him
to where the firebird is and so yvonne
rides this wolf
through the great lands and reaches to
another kingdom and in the russian fairy
tales it's always amazing it's always
like
you know the tenth kingdom or the you
know the tenth of the third ten
times three kingdoms or there's always
this kind of way of describing it which
is really wonderful
um and so yvonne arrives and the
the uh firebird warns him he says no not
the firebird the gray wolf warns him
that when he gets the firebird he's
going to find the firebird
in a golden cage and that he should take
the firebird
but not take the golden cage so yvonne
goes out
gets to the firebird and of course he
cannot resist
and he goes to take the golden cage and
these brass trumpets start to blare
and the king of the kingdom catches him
yvonne tells him his story and the king
says why didn't you tell me
that you wanted the firebird if you just
asked for it i would have given it to
you
but he said maybe if you do me a favor i
can help you out
so the king says that he really would
like to have
a this horse in another kingdom this
horse with a golden mane
and that if prince yvonne can get for
him this horse with a golden mane
then he will give him the firebird and
so prince yvonne goes to see the wolf
and the wolf says don't worry i will
take you to where the
horse with the golden mane is so they
leave together and
you know the the the gray wolf brings
him to where the horse is
once again a similar situation presents
itself
itself the horse tells prince yvonne
that
now the horse i keep confusing the
characters is not helping you
the gray wolf tells prince yvonne that
he should take
the horse but not take the golden bridle
that is holding the horse down and that
you know
so prince yvonne goes in and of course
same situation he cannot resist
he tries to take the bridle these brass
trumpets blair and the king comes out
they catch him and
again the prince says why didn't you
tell me that you wanted the horse if you
just told me
then i would have given it to you of
course these these kings are recognizing
in prince evan that he is the son of
a king from another kingdom and so he
would he said as as the son
of a of a king if you would ask me for
it i would have given it to you
and so either but now the uh
the king has also a favor it says if you
do this favor for me then i will let you
have
the horse with the golden mane you need
to find for me
helen the beautiful and if you bring
back helen the beautiful for me
then i will give you the horse
and so the apprentice van gogh sees the
wolf of course and the wolf brings her
brings him to where the princess is but
this time the wolf says look you know
what i'm gonna do it
and you just hang out here i will get
the princess for you so we avoid getting
into
more trouble and so the wolf goes in he
grabs the princess away from his
maidserv
her maidservants and brings the princess
to prince ivan
he takes the princess on the back of the
wolf and as their writing
the princess and prince evan fall in
love
as they're going towards the king the
the first kingdom
when they arrive at the kingdom where
he's supposed to trade her for
the for the golden horse prince ivan is
crying and says i can't give her up i
love her and she loves me
and what what are we to do and so the
wolf says don't worry i
will take care of it just go on your way
and i will come meet you
so prince ivan and the princess go on
their way and the wolf
goes in and he
pretends to be the princess he turns
into the princess transforms into her
and so he's received by the king
and the king uh gives i forget obviously
the order is wrong he
prince ivan brings the princess to the
king and then the king gives prince
yvonne the horse
and he leaves the wolf with the king so
that
the wolf says don't worry there that's
when he says i'm going to meet you
further down
sorry i'm getting the events confused so
prince yvonne then leaves with
the horse and the princess on his way
to go exchange the horse for the
um the firebird on his then when the
wolf sees that he has an opportunity he
escapes
meets with prince ivan and they get to
the place where they're supposed to make
the trade but when they get there prince
evan is like well i don't want to give
up
this beautiful horse with its golden
mane what should i do
so the wolf once again says don't worry
i will take care of it
and so he transforms into the whole
horse with the golden mane
and prince yvonne brings the the horse
to the king
and gets the firebird the
once again the wolf says go on your way
i will meet you
and prince yvonne leaves with the golden
horse
and the princess and when the wolf has
an opportunity he escapes
meets with prince yvonne and then they
get to
the place where the wolf ate his horse
and this is where the wolf says look
this is the place where i ate your horse
i don't owe you anything anymore and so
i
will let you guys go on your way
so prince yvonne and the princess on the
horse start to return to the kingdom
when they arrive at the place where the
three roads met
they settle down and they fall asleep
that's when the two brothers see prince
ivan
the horse the princess and the golden
and the firebird so the two brothers
jealous decide amongst themselves that
they're going to kill prince yvonne
and take his treasure so they kill
prince yvonne they cut him into pieces
and they leave with the princess with
the firebird and the horse and go back
to the king when the king is happy to
receive his firebird
and you know he gives the different
things to half the kingdom and one of
them marries the princess and
it not it doesn't marry but will be the
one to marry the princess
the other person gets the kingdom et
cetera et cetera and there is prince
ivan in
in cut into pieces and he stays there
dead for a month
in the some of the versions
after a month one day the wolf catching
the prince's scent
comes upon the dead body the cut up body
and he sees that these crows this family
of crows is about
to come down and to eat prince yvonne
and so the wolf catches the baby crows
and he tells the mother crow if you
don't go and get for me
the water of life and the water of death
you know at the edge of the world or
whatever you know what on the
the 10th of 30th kingdom or whatever
some some kind of you know magical
really far away number then i will
devour your children
and so the crow goes away and brings
back the water of life and the water of
death
to the wolf so the wolf
kills one of the baby crows kind of cuts
it in half or whatever
chops it and he pours on the crow first
the water of death
which brings the crow back to one piece
then he pours on the baby crow the water
of life
which reanimates it so now the gray wolf
knows that he has the right thing
turns towards prince yvonne and does the
same pours on him the water of death
by which all his pieces come together
and join into one body
and then he pours on him the water of
life
which awakens him and vivifies him and
when prince ivan wakes
you know gets up he thinks that he's
been sleeping and he's waking from a
profound sleep
so the wolf tells him about everything
that's going on and that his brother
stole his
bride stole his horse stole the bird and
so prince ivan and the wolf go to meet
with
the uh the king and you know tells the
whole story to the king and their
version where
the brothers are killed were they eaten
by the wolf and
somewhere they're in prison whatever
that's not a big that's not the most
important what's important is that
prince yvonne finally marries his
princess
and also inherits the kingdom and has
his
horse so everything and everybody well
not
everybody but let's say some people live
happily
ever after and so what is
going on now i would really suggest that
if you know i told you this version very
quickly and very summarily but i would
really suggest that you go listen
to deacon nicholas's retelling even
maybe before
i give you this interpretation you might
find it very
fascinating what i really need you to do
first of all is
to buckle up to a certain extent because
i'm really going to try to give you an
interpretation of this fairy tale
one of the things about russian fairy
tales that is amazing is just
how cosmic they are they have not gone
through the kind of moralizing lens
that many of our fairy tales have gone
through during the enlightenment where
there was this desire to make them into
simple morality tales
which are not at their basis in this
fairy tale we really get
a full cosmic vision a full vision of
the cosmic
image and so what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to do something
a little fun is i'm going to use the
image of everything that i designed
to kind of give you a road map to
understand
this fairy tale so what it's going to do
is it's not only going to
give you a it's not only going to help
you understand the fairy tale but it's
also going to help you see how this
image
first of all is not arbitrary that this
image
is meant to be a kind of map of the
cosmos
in in a way that you can also use
through analogy
to then look at the world and see the
patterns that appear there
of course the image of everything that i
designed is not the only image there are
other images of everything
and they could all they could have
different forms they don't necessarily
all have to
have the same form this is one manner in
which you can represent
the the cosmic pattern which is of
course not with the cosmic pattern is of
course
invisible at the outset all right and so
now the situation starts with the idea
that the king
has this tree of golden apples now
if you notice everything in the fairy
tale is golden this
happens in a lot of fairy tales it has
to do with the idea of them being
special or the highest version of
something
and so the they shine with light okay
and so they glow
this is the notion of glowing you see it
also in the firebird
this idea of something which glows uh is
something which is special
which is like i said the highest version
of it
in terms of phenomena i've mentioned
this in terms of
the notion of um attention
and our capacity to attend to things and
how
this the way they are special is the
manner in which we
notice them right as someone you know
will glow more than a stranger
and this glow is the glow that is
um ultimately referred to not of course
not the glow of a friend but the notion
of meaning of
fullness you know of the highest version
of something
in your experience of it and so the the
golden tree is in a way the
highest thing that the king has access
to it is the fruit
of you know you can imagine it as the
center of his garden and so
if you look at the image you see the
notion of this garden this enclosed
space
and then in the center would be the tree
which has golden fruits
you know in this case the tree is
more the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil maybe not the highest highest
tree that is
that is something which comes later in
the story
and so this notion of this tree with
golden fruit
and this is also where you're going to
see and this might be difficult for some
people to deal with
but i've often mentioned that
symbolism is not moral and that some
stories will take on certain patterns
and will
manifest them at different on different
sides of the same story
this is of course where you're going to
see something similar
you know the idea that the fruit of the
knowledge of good and evil was bad of
course is not true
in the tradition there's this idea that
god if adam and eve had been humble god
would have given them
the fruit okay so it's a good fruit and
it's also a fruit which leads to higher
spiritual knowledge
and so this is the tree that the the
king has you could
see it as the highest insight that the
king has access to in terms of knowledge
in terms of understanding
you can see it that way you could just
see it as the most precious thing that
he has it it can
apply different levels of reality and so
something is coming to steal
his apples and this happens to be
the firebird now the firebird is of
course
in different versions it's represented
not only as a firebird but as
a glowing bird or a bird of light right
and it is this heavenly influence or
this heavenly thing
above and like i said we tend to think
of the heavenly influence as something
which is positive but sometimes it is
also
negative it can be negative in the sense
that it can
pick things pick seeds and
bring them up into the heavens and
prevent them
from being on the earth i mentioned this
in terms of some ideas sometimes which
you know they're just floating up in the
air and they never seem to
land there's this idea that that which
is above can come down and pick that
which is below
and bring it up to its use this can be
seen in terms of spiritual reality but
it can also be seen in terms of
understanding that a king will do the
same to his kingdom so the
the the firebird comes down picks the
king's apples and brings them up but the
king
goes down into his kingdom picks the
best
men for his army picks the best women
you know like king david for
or king solomon for his for his court
uh and so this is one of the aspects of
heaven is that it comes down and it
takes
the best up right it takes the first
fruits
in terms of the sacrifice it takes the
best and
brings it up into heaven okay this is
how hierarchy works
and so now this thing from heaven comes
down something which is above the king
and comes down and takes the golden
apples and of course the king doesn't
want his golden apples to go away
especially if you understand the golden
apples as something like his insight or
something like
his hit the best that he has
and so he wants to catch the bird um
here is where the story refers even
more so towards the idea of knowledge
and of insight because
we see that the reason why the
two sons can't catch that which is above
is because
they fall asleep they can't be into
contact which that was above because
they let themselves
fall into death you could say and so
prince yvonne stays awake remember the
story of christ who's up on the mountain
and who tells the disciples to stay
awake at the bottom of the mountain
while he prays
so while he is up and communing with the
heavens
he asks for the disciples to stay awake
so that they can benefit from what is
happening at the top of the mountain
this is the similar situation the prince
the princes have to stay awake but they
don't they fall asleep
they don't catch the inside they don't
receive the the positive aspect
of the spiritual influence and prince
ivan on
on different from them is able to remain
attentive
he's able to remain awake and attentive
and because of that
he's able to catch the inside but not
totally
he's not completely capable of catching
the inside he only catches the remainder
of the inside he only catches the
feather
and brings the feather back to his
father now
in terms of knowledge i think pretty
much everybody has had that experience
where
you have an insight but then when you
try to formulate it
you can't formulate it properly you
don't have the words for it you
you you uh you only have a pale
remainder
of the insight or the spiritual vision
or the
the the moment of of the small
connection spiritual connection that you
have
you don't have the capacity to explain
it and that is what prince yvonne
staying with only the bird's feather is
talking about now of course
i keep i'm gonna keep moving you know at
different levels of ontological reality
to help you understand
what this is about but notice that it's
not of course just about knowledge it's
about
all kinds of other things but this is
the best way to maybe understand it
uh in this case okay
you can understand it in another way you
could say that you know
someone who receives an opportunity
which comes from above let's say a favor
a king's favor and then is not able to
make it
uh grow is not able to to make it
produce more than you know very little
and so you get this thing from above
but you're not able to make it worth
something it kind of falls flat you know
that's
that's one another way of explaining the
experience of prince yvonne in this
moment
but of course the king even the feather
for him
is already more than what he has access
to
is already more than what he can have
and so he wants
to get the bird because he is
he is dazzled by just the feather of the
bird and so he wants it
um and so he asks his son to go
catch the bird now you need to you need
to wonder why the king himself isn't
going to catch the bird
but in a way ultimately you also kind of
have to understand
that the sons are always also an
extension of the father so you can
imagine
the father looking at different aspects
of his kingdom to see if they
can capture this insight different
aspects of himself
different aspects of his kingdom to see
if they have the capacity
to host the insight to to to catch it
okay so the two
suns go now the thing about this
is that in order this is now the place
where there's
actually a fall and you might wonder you
know
why why is it now that there would be a
fall
why is it that this moment
throws the whole situation in a loop
you know you cannot understand it of
course if you want to understand it as
the hero's journey
as the call to adventure which is also
this going down
into the underworld going down into
death uh
all of this is what's going on here but
it is also
a form of moving into the world
of death and of suffering in order to
find
the body in order to find the capacity
to connect with this this
first event that happened right this
first
moment of the the firebird and
leaving of his feather so in order to do
so you have to go
out and you have to kind of go into
death and this is what happens
now here it's not necessarily seen as a
fall
per se it's just seen as a going out
into adventure
but let's say in the cosmic image that i
that i've drawn
it is represented of course also as
it's represented as the fall but there
are different ways of understanding the
fall
i've noticed i've mentioned in the past
that for example saint irenaeus
talks about adam and eve as being
children
something like children who although the
fall was
was not good we couldn't say that the
fall was good but it was nonetheless
a kind of pedagogical tool
to get them to become more than what
they they were and so this is something
that you can see as well so the king's
sons are
going out to find the firebird but in
doing so they're also going to
become men they're also going to show
that they're worthy of replacing the
king not just by finding the firebird
but by by vanquishing the very
uh the very challenge that the king is
giving them is also
going to show how they are the ones who
can inherit the kingdom okay
and so prince yvonne so the two go out
and they come
to the result of death that is they
leave
the the safety of the kingdom and they
face multiplicity they come to the fact
that they
now have to choose this is important to
understand because
saint maximus the confessor for example
talks about how
the idea of choice that we have the idea
that we choose between different paths
like this
that is not the highest form of will
the highest form of will is a will which
is directly connected to reality
which doesn't choose but expresses
itself
in pure conjunction with how the world
is laying itself out
and so it actually looks like you're not
choosing in the conventional cell
sense where it's like you have options
and you choose the different options
this is of course the same thing
this is of course the same thing as adam
and eve go down
the the hill go down the or chase from
the garden
they will face a world where they have
to choose
where multiplicity will present itself
to them as a
as a quandary that they have to solve
whereas in the garden
they didn't have the prop multiplicity
wasn't a problem for them
it wasn't something which presented
suffering let's say
and here is where the choice
multiplicity
and suffering come together in this
moment where the two sons
find the sign and the three the three
possibilities of either going on the
road which will
um which will bring them cold and
suffering
and then you can understand it as three
roads so one in the
one let's say going down straight down
and then one going to the right and one
going to the left okay
and one is this road of let's say pure
suffering which is just going down
into death okay and then one of them is
the two opposites so if you look at the
image of the cosmic
mountain on the two sides are the two
opposites they're
let's say the going up and going down
okay you can understand the two
opposites in different ways
and here you can see the two opposites
one is
that let's say death will cause a
separation
of the body and the soul so the the
horse
of the writer is the an extension of his
body
this is something that is maybe
difficult for some people to understand
but when every time you hear of a mount
in any story it is an extension of that
person just like a sword or like
any any supplement that is added to
someone
is a is an extension of themselves now
if you haven't noticed for example that
in the story of
how to train your dragon you see this
very clearly where each dragon that is
becomes the mount of the different
vikings
is an expression of that person is like
a lower expression
of the person who is mounting them and
this is of course what amount is it's
like it's like adding body to yourself
okay so you add animality it's a garment
of skin you add animality to yourself
and you have more power because you have
a mount and you can go faster
you can pull things you can do all these
things because you're adding power to
yourself
you know you can see this going all the
way to a car
or to you know other types of technology
which increase your power but the mount
is the most prima
is one of the most primordial ones and
so
one of them is that the body and the
head will separate
you know and the head will survive but
the body will die
the other one is the opposite where the
body and the head will separate
but the head will die and the body will
survive
and so you have these kind of two
opposites which are represented in
different ways if you look at the image
you have the white bird and the
blackbird
so in one image the head survives and in
the other image the body
survives so it's these two these two
movements and then down the middle is
going down
into death so prince yvonne chooses
chooses rightly he's smart because i
mean he's smart because he chooses the
one in which
his horse is going to die and
so he loses his body and because of that
he loses his power
and he can't get he can't do what he
wanted to do he loses
you know he he sacrificed his his power
and
in a way there is a manner in which
you could you could see it as a as a
kind of form of asceticism
um you could see it as a form of
sacrifice as well
that he kind of sacrificed this animal
in order to be able to survive
and so he suffers for a while because he
kind of wanders and he can't
he can't find he's like a wandering
ghost let's say who can't find a body
and so he can't accomplish anything he
can't do anything
and that's when he meets the wolf that
ate his
horse and now if you you need to
understand the wolf
also as an extension of yvonne the wolf
is his mount as well but now this is a
different kind of mount it is a wild
mount it is a mount which has something
of
the of the the trickiness of the snake
the power of the animal
and so it's not a tamed mount like the
one he had
but it's a wild mount and there and it
has
much more power than what the other
amount has but it also
has much more danger so you can
understand it in many ways
you can understand it as this this let's
say
i i've mentioned this before you can
imagine imagine it first of all
in yourself as a more wild aspect of
yourself
as your more irratible nature your more
passionate nature you can understand it
in times of a person
you can understand it in terms of a
country where
you know uh there's so many examples
where the king
will get a personal guard of barbarians
to protect him
because he's taking this foreign strange
power to himself and it's it's adding
more power than if he took his own
people
because of this kind of foreign element
with this strange element
this wild element if you're able to
mount it it will give you
way more power but it also has more
danger that is
another part of it and it's the same you
know in yourself
if you're if you need to tap into anger
if you need to tap
into those more irratible passions that
you have
you will see that it will give you
extreme power and
it's a it's a power that can make you
drunk it's dangerous power
but it is power nonetheless and if you
have
holy anger for example you can
accomplish
pretty much anything and so here the
wolf now brings him
to the first place of course in the
in the cosmic image you can understand
this as
increasing the layers the the different
layers that cover adam and eve
increasing the animality in which adam
and eve are plunged
you can see it as this putting on the
garments of skin
down at the bottom of the image moving
from the
lighter covering which is the the
leaf covering to the animal covering
below
but here it's more the idea of moving
from the tame animal
to the wild animal it's too much to go
into here but
you see that distinction in the creation
narrative as well
where there's a when it talks about the
different animals
it talks about let's say domesticated
animals and wild animals
as these two opposites or two aspects of
reality and so because
prince yvonne could not catch the bird
which was coming from
above he has to free it from
an are already from a cage he has to
find it in the world
and he has to be able to to get it from
there now
there are many ways to understand this
you can understand it in terms of
knowledge
understanding in terms of knowledge at
least in my sense seems to be
a good way to understand it but you can
understand that if you have an insight
and you can't
let's say you lose it or you lose the
capacity to embody it properly
the best way then to recapture that
insight is to look at the analogies
is to look back into the world and to
see if you can't
perceive a glimmer of that spiritual
insight that you had you
look in scripture you look in the
tradition you look
in in in depending on what the insight
is that you have
you will look in the world and try to
free it
from another body try to free it from
another place where
you find it so that you can kind of pick
it out right
and then see it once again okay and this
is what
is is happening but
the here you have this opposite being
set up the wolf says
attend to the inside but don't
take the outside don't take the thing
tying it down
if you want the insight take the bird
but don't take the body if you want the
insight
you need to be able to see the insight
in the world but if you need to
be able to also be careful not to
confuse or to take
just take the body as well if you want
that insight
you know so if i'm looking for analogies
i need to not get too attached to those
analogies
not get too attached to the examples but
be able to weed
the inside out of the cage okay
so you even if the cage is precious and
the cage is nice you need to leave the
cage don't take the cage
and so because um prince yvonne takes
the cage then he's thrown into another
loop another loop of having to now
go find something else okay and and of
course prince evan now
is also in the world of death he's in
the world of the stranger
and he's using the tricks
of this of that world he's using
thievery he's using
he's using let's say things that aren't
good
to now try to find that insight now
like i said symbolism is not moral and
there's plenty of examples where you see
this happen i talked about jack and the
beanstalk
there are different stories where you
can see the use of thievery and trickery
to try to get
the uh the the insight you know and
sometimes it can be justified in the
story of jacob you see that that's what
he does
the story of jacob is very similar to
these types of stories where jacob goes
to la ban and in order to get his wife
he
he tricks laban but he also ends up
taking his
his livestock and he ends up you know he
he's also tricked as well this is
something that will happen to prince
ivan
also but he's engaging in that kind of
behavior ways
where he's stealing the thing and it's
funny because the king says
if you had used logos like if you if you
had used the tools
of meaning to get this insight
then you i would have given it to you
but instead you're not
you're not i mean you it's gonna work in
the end but it's gonna be very painful
the whole process is like a fall
all of it's gonna be very painful and
the king is saying if you had only used
the tools of light you could say
then you would have gotten it but no you
need to go the hard way
you need to go all the way around you
need to suffer and you need to to
to go through the hard part and so okay
fine you try to steal it you try to get
the cage
and now you have to go on another loop
and you have to go get now the horse
with the golden mane
so prince ivan now you had he had to get
something above
right and now he has to get something
below so
it is he's going down okay he has to get
something below which is another mount
now this golden mount
which is related to his horse which is
related to the idea of that which is
above
to the mount and so he goes and the same
thing happens again
there is something about the the
there's something that's not it's
similar to the the the bird where he
also is trying to get some kind of
insight in the mount he's trying to get
it's not the same high insight as the
firebird but there's also
some inside because the the horse has a
golden mane
um and once again he's told take
the horse but don't take that which ties
it down don't take that which
is holding it to the world right if you
want to get the most of it
don't be attached to that which is
around it right
to its covering to its shell
of course prince yvonne makes the same
mistake same thing happens the king said
if you'd only use the tools of light if
you'd only
use logos then you would have gotten it
i would have given it to you but instead
you go the hard way so now third way
you go
now the third one is to get helen the
beautiful
this is now becomes very interesting
because
all of a sudden you know i don't know if
in the russian it's meant to be that but
at least for an english speaker when you
see hell in the beautiful you of course
think of the story of the trojan war and
you
remember that in the story of the trojan
war there is also
a story of golden apples and the whole
conflict starts with a problem about
wanting a golden apple and
a you know this competition to seduce
paris
between the goddesses and then uh
you know the prince chooses to get helen
of troy and this is what kind of sends
the whole thing into
a loop as well so that's just
fascinating to mention it seems like
it's it's referencing that as well
but here the idea and this is going to
sound strange to sal
to some but now he's actually getting
the lowest thing and now the lowest
thing appears not
as something negative in the sense of
bad but lois in the sense of the grail
in the sense of the the pristine cup in
the sense of the virgin
that is his last quest so he's moving
down
from the from the from the high insight
down but then this is the the kind of
the trick or the mystery which is that
one of the highest insights actually is
in the grail when
one once one of the highest insights is
in
this pure container which is the pure
beauty or
you know unadulterated beauty the idea
of the virgin the idea of the mother of
god of course
ultimately and so this is this is now
the let's say this is
in his quest he's going to now try to
get that get the grail and so
this is also fascinating because until
now
the prince ivan doesn't really care
about
the things that he's getting he doesn't
care about the firebird he didn't care
about the golden apples he
didn't care about the horse with the
golden mane he's just kind of
he just kind of wants to please his
father um
and this is in a in a way as he goes
down
and he goes out into adventure and he
goes down into death is the place where
he will then discover
in a certain manner his own being
in his own agency you could say
where he and this is like i said he's
neither negative or positive but he's
going to start to
experience attachment and desire in his
own sense and here in the story it's not
seen as
bad in other stories it could be seen as
bad in this story it's not seen as bad
where prince yvonne you know when the
wolf brings him to princess now he falls
in love with the princess
and the the falling in love with the
princess also makes him
care about the other things he also
wants the horse
and he also wants you know he wants the
different things because
he he he now is in love with this
princess he now
is attached to the world
you could say but this is also the place
where the effect of death where the use
of trickery will
become more and more apparent and now
the the thing that he desires
that his irratible quality his desiring
quality his
mount right the thing which drives him
forward the thing which
supports him and his power is going to
take the shape
of the things that he desires and that
is going to make him have access to
those things
right and so this is what's going on the
wolf takes on the shape of that which he
desires
and then he is able to get it and in a
manner also through an
act of trickery this is of course in the
world of death
is where you start to see these loops of
trickery so he tricks
once tricks twice but that of course
it's not a way to live it's you can't
you can't continue that way he's entered
into
the place of multiplicity and this is
where you see
what the place of multiplicity is
because when ivan gets back to the place
where he discovered multiplicity
the place where the paths split into
three that's the place
where he also dies because that's what
it's been from the beginning
it's been death from the beginning from
the beginning of the story this whole
process has been a process
of death and you see it in the story
you've seen in the story because it's
about
the water of life and the water of death
but this whole loop
has been prince yvonne going down into
death and it
manifests itself completely when he kind
of comes back to this point you've seen
this loop in death
but now you see the you see it again you
could say but to help you understand
what this whole thing was from the
beginning
which is this relationship between
desire and death and multiplicity
and the desire for multiple things all
of this stuff
now it let's say happens to him where he
is killed
by his brothers and he's chopped into
pieces that is of course the ultimate
representation
of the fragmentation of the breaking
apart of the body which happens at the
bottom
of the mountain and so prince yvonne is
killed
and is broken apart and
everything that he loved is taken away
from him
and so this is where let's say the
mystery
of the transformation finally completely
occurs
now prince ivan is about to be baptized
and this is of course like i said it's
not a christian story and so you can't
totally see the christian
elements in it but nonetheless the the
the place where he is right now in the
story
is akin to the place where he is about
to be baptized
and so the you have to see
the you have to see now the
the wolf comes and he tells the birds
that he takes the baby birds now
you have to to see the black bird and
the white bird
as related in the story you have the
the bird of light the firebird and you
have the bird of death
which is the blackbird and
the bird of light is picking the fruits
from the tree and bringing them up above
and now
this wolf who's at the bottom and this
relationship with the bird of death is
rather
just pulling down or you can say right
so you have this this
these birds that are coming to eat the
carcass
not take the seeds you know the
difference between the
a bird that eats the seeds in the tree
and a bird like a crow that eats the
dead bodies on the ground okay so you
see this opposite
in the story these two sides if you look
at the image again of the cosmos you see
the white bird of the blackbird
the bird that noah sent out and came
back and the bird that noah sent out and
now
ended up feeding on dead bodies in the
water according to some of the
the artistic tradition so the wall and
so now you're at the bottom of the
mountain you could say in a way you've
kind of been at the bottom of the
mountain the whole time
this whole thing has been kind of a
cycle of going down the mountain and
showing what the bottom of the mountain
is in terms of multiplicity
desire you know uh attachment to
things and also but ultimately the
mystery of the grail which is the
transformative mystery which is also at
the
bottom of the world you could say but
all of this is kind of
this is what's great about stories is
that you can show the story and it's
because it's it shows you the positive
and the negative aspects
of this process that it's happening so
he tells the blackbird to bring him
the water of life and the water of death
you can imagine it as
the water which is coming down from the
garden right that's flowing down
which is the source which is the water
of life it's the water that
christ talks about the water that
the living water the fountain of youth
all this image of the fountain which
brings life
in like say in christian tradition but
in in all kinds of traditions you find
this idea of the water of life
which comes down from above and then the
water of death which is
represented let's say as the ocean or
the salt water which is below and which
you can't drink
and so he the bird brings the two waters
together and this is where
he will be baptized now baptism it's
interesting because
you do have these two like competing
narratives about baptism
where you have this sense that baptism
is a descent
into death and so you put someone down
in the water and then there's another
version which is the sprinkling from
above which you see mostly in catholic
baptism
where they sprinkle the the person with
water on top
um if you look at early images of
baptism you see that it's both together
you see
christ is in the water and then you see
saint john the baptist
pouring water on top of his head it's
both at the same time it's both
going into the water of death but
somehow this water of death also joining
or
getting the the getting
the the positive aspect of the water of
life
um and the water of death is there to
bring things together into one now what
why
why is it this has to do it's difficult
because we we don't tend to think that
way but it has to do of course with the
the purifying effect of water
it has to do with the idea of
you have a lot of stuff on your hands
and then you wash your hands
and so and then you remove all that is
you remove the multiplicity and now here
it's not
so much that removes the multiplicity
but that it kind of
fixes them together this of course
intuitively you know
in certain arts you can understand that
water also does that it fixes things
sometimes
especially cold water if you imagine
imagine metallurgy where they heat the
flame they heat the sword so that it
becomes malleable and then they put it
down
into the water to fix it and so this is
what's going on
in the water of death where the body
kind of finds itself just the body and
so remember this whole thing from the
beginning
has been about the body and the the soul
in the body or the above and the below
the the separation of the head and the
body all of this has been there from the
beginning
but now you can see the two coming
together where there is a
let's say a bringing together of the
body and then
a pouring of the water of life which
vivifies the body now
there could be different ways of
representing it in scripture it's
represented as the gathering of the dust
of adam into a body and then the blowing
of the spirit into the nostrils of adam
now the the let's say though going down
into the fixing waters to kind of fix
the the shape
and then having living water pour down
up upon it
is of course a very similar pattern um
f understanding that in many ancient
mythologies as well
the relationship between heaven and
earth or above and below
was represented by the intertwining
of fresh water and salt water for
example in the story of
of tiamat for example which is this this
there's a joining of heaven and earth as
the fresh water and the salt water
and so this is the resurrection of
ivan so yvonne resurrects he's gone
through the adventure he's gone through
death he has died to himself and now
he's back he has
let's say become more than what he was
before and now he is
ready you could say to claim
the kingdom and that's what happens he
goes
finds his father and he's able to
reclaim the kingdom
but in order to do so he had to go
through this
this reawakening
from sleep right and you can understand
his death when he's cut apart
and his sleep with the princess and the
horse
all being the same thing and now he does
finally awake you see it
of course in the story when he he comes
back from death
he's also sees himself as awakening and
so you could understand
there's so many ways you can understand
it you can understand the whole loop of
him going down
as a kind of dream or the whole loop of
him going down
as this like i said going down into
death
uh going down into forgetting going down
into desire
all of these things going down into his
passions
all of these things make sense because
the story is so versatile
that it can be applied in different ways
to different things
and then finally prince ivan comes back
inherits the kingdom from
replaces the king ultimately becomes the
new king
and inherits the kingdom
and so i hope that this was helpful and
the image of course the final image and
i know some people will
will might be a little bit annoyed that
i point of course
this story is not the story of christ it
is
it is not comparable to the story of
christ the story of christ is much
bigger much wider much
broader than all of this but nonetheless
this the story because it is so cosmic
cannot help
but point to the story of christ in
different ways some of them more broken
than others
but in the end what you see is the image
of christ
crucified at the top of the hill which
is
that you can imagine
not just crucified but also let's say if
you can imagine the image of the
crucifixion
and the resurrection at the same time or
the descent into hades that's all of
this at the same time
this is the final image where for having
died
for having gone through this prince
yvonne you know
his kingship is higher than what it
would have been if he didn't go through
that if he hadn't gone through death
in my brother's book he talks about the
idea of
space crowned with time that that to
receive the crown
is also to have integrated some aspect
of death or to have used death against
death and this is something which the
whole time prince evan is dealing with
and so there could be so many more
things to say but i just wanted
to give you a little hint of how much
there is in these fairy tales
just how much
depth there is in these stories and so
that is one of the reasons why i'm
extremely excited to see deacon nicholas
go on this journey into russian fairy
tales slavic fairy tales are amazing
i also love czech fairy tales for
example my wife is from
uh the slovak from slovakia and the the
fairy tales from that area are wonderful
as well so i'm really looking forward to
hear deacon nicholas talk about baba
yaga
and about all the very fascinating
characters
in russian fairy tales and give us a
little hint of
their meaning so everybody i hope this
has been useful to you
and i thank you for your attention hope
you enjoyed this discussion
of the fairy tale of prince yvonne and
the gray wolf
as you know the symbolic world is much
more than just these videos it's also a
podcast which you can find on most
podcast platforms it's also a website
where we have multiple people writing
some pretty amazing articles on the
subject of symbolism
we also have a facebook group which is a
little harder to
get to you actually have to apply and
maybe answer a few questions
but the discussion there is amazing and
many of the articles
are based on the rich discussion that is
happening in there there are some people
coming up some amazing people with some
great ideas
coming up in that world so please
continue to pay attention visit the
website
and don't forget to support us if you
can go to symbolicworld.com
support or you can also buy some
products for all of which will be listed
below
check out the links also for the new
podcast by deacon nicholas
i will put that as well as links to his
website and to his writing so thanks
everybody and i will talk to you very
soon